hello and welcome mrs. video playing
Colonel massive Nikolai enrich Cena wow-
for i keep getting people prepared
against people where you have terrible
scores what's happening here yeah the
triangle this is my line against a
triangle usually I'm fairing quite well
with it check Wow should be 4i guess
and this is a very Sean line with Bishop
b4 and white has to play a three I think
Black has those ideas with g5 and so
something very sharp 83 that something
very very sharp in a 3g five Bishop
chief me know g5 Bishop g3 g4 long
castles or something like that it's a
very strange line okay loop the 1 i'm
not quite sure what it was as usual
everything is easy and played instantly
okay but am I not able to play this
rookie one now okay one I've bishop d6
the bishop tags let's see you can play
age for me
i also had long castles maybe i should
have considered that also but then i'm
losing on time which is probably how I
lost most of the gains games against
them I'm just speculating but it's often
pretty decent bad yes interesting move k
should be five this f6
I have to do that I hope maybe maybe he
had h takes 23 maybe he had that move I
would have been really cool yeah well
I'm not very happy with this here to be
honest but it's a what happened to do
this and now it takes me form check
maybe long castles was better added so
this is a very sharp line and I didn't
didn't remember the details
have to castle and things are still not
totally clear
spish upon CA it still sucks and also
not so clear ways king is going
you
okay so Q&A forum
I think I should just wind a porno I
don't really see how he keeps it okay
one gue ke to this kind of thing some
tactics maybe takes on c4
okay I don't want to tread Queens this
is what I no definitely not
you
the ship a sixth is rook a3 now ok I can
take now on a 3 which is probably not
bad I just wonder maybe there was
something bad ok cannot be bad and
that's a blundering stuff but you can
play Bishop e7 maybe
i also have potential efore at some
point the Queen on c1 is eyeing that
pawn on d5 okay seven looks right now if
for attacking that pawn I can take it i
guess i'm not back when mated there are
two pieces looking at everyone and so I
think I can take check and now I can
check when you add that doesn't really
it doesn't net that much okay I'm not be
sure to detect hmm so what's best here
maybe a Quincy five wasn't that great
actually
time warning it's not so clear for my
movies here amazingly i should have
thought about this a moment
let's don't see a clear move here
amazing when g8 doesn't win there should
be six doesn't win
yeah I just got outplayed in this
position that was completely winning
great great stuff check check check
check check white yeah yeah that's
that's how things happen in your queen
takes f 2 at the end yeah anyway yeah
but this is really disappointing they're
not winning from this position just just
it just terribly bad for black this is a
mistake probably as easy as it looks but
okay no d 5 wins but I couldn't see how
I probably did six huh I didn't see g6r
that's strong at is strong and it
doesn't even have a check here wow
that's very strong and then i have
looked be 70 that's it's not this is not
easy to see and this is made
okay now well then I don't have to I saw
that but at least six I couldn't really
couldn't really see how that wins after
this rupee seven okay yeah this was kind
of Bishop b5 so that's good but I should
just play the five-year this is a lot
easier to play with no time on no time I
have much more time that's a lot easier
check guarantee I just I just couldn't
believe i have no when I have a have no
one I have no win then you blonde with
the rook and chat I lost some time at
the end check check yeah anyway I want
to check the opening quickly because i'm
pretty sure that I then I made some
mistake there this is right and I think
G for long castles is what what happens
isn't that right actually Queen D 1 it's
good
well I'm not sure that I would have
remembered that but it looks good yeah
it really does this is this is just nice
for white thing like there's this white
has a very good position here but he
played this and now maybe castles long
is stronger i played this reasonably
quickly but maybe this is stronger
because i'm actually now threatening a
form so that if he goes here i just take
take he and win the game which wasn't
possible of course in there in the
actual game yeah here it was an
interesting position but i think i think
black is certainly okay now but this was
probably too ambitious he just marched
the a porn and here i'm getting getting
this pawn and just have a good position
I don't I don't think um that was good
but he was okay before of course it's
all very complicated bit of a
disappointment that happened one of this
game thanks for watching